[Music]
the theme of this conference today is
agents at work unfortunately for the
next 18 minutes you'll be stuck with me
talking about how agents don't work very
well today and how we can do better when
it comes to AI engineering ing so there
is so much interest in Agents from all
fronts in the product world and in the
industry World in academic labs in
research if you're someone who doesn't
think that companies will be able to
scale language models all the way to AGI
and what we're going to see more and
more of in the near future is agents
that are not really deployed directly
but function as small parts of larger
products and systems and this is what AI
is probably going to look like in the
near future swix came up with a few
dozen definitions of AI agents this is
one of them where language models
control the flow of a particular
system in fact even when people naively
think of um chat GPT and Claw as models
uh these tools are actually examples of
rudimentary agents at some level they
have input and output filters uh they
can carry out certain tasks they can
call these tools and so on so in some
sense agents are already widely used as
well as
successful we've now seen mainstream
product offerings uh that can do a lot
more open AI operator can carry out
open-ended tasks on the internet the
Deep research tool can carry out 30
minute long report writing tasks on any
conceivable
topic so that's the first reason I think
today's conference is timely but the
second reason is that on the flip side
the more ambiti ambitious visions of
what agent can do are far from being
realized so on the left here is a vision
for what agents can do something out of
Science Fiction films like the film her
and on the right hand side are how these
ambitious products have failed in the
real world so far now I'm pointing this
out not to criticize the specific
products on the slide but to genuinely
challenge the audience into the
challenge of building AI agents that
really work for the people who are about
to use them and so over the course of
this talk I'll talk about three main
reasons why agents don't yet work and
what we can do to realize the potential
of agents to get past some of these
failures the first one is that
evaluating agents is genuinely hard so
to begin let's see some examples of how
when people have tried to productionize
agents these agents have sort of failed
in the real
world do not pay is a US startup that
claimed to automate the entire work of a
lawyer um the startup co-founder even
offered a million dollar for any lawyer
who would be willing to argue in front
of the US Supreme Court using do not pay
in an
earpiece in reality a couple of years
later in fact very recently the FTC fine
do not pay hundreds of thousands of
dollars the reason for the fine was that
the performance claims that do not play
seem to be making were actually entirely
false now you might consider this a case
of Rush invention of a small startup
making claims that it cannot back so
let's look at some of the work from more
wellestablished
companies Law Firm Nexus Lexus Nexus as
well as West law are widely regarded to
be some of the leading lawtech firms in
the US a couple of years ago Lexus Nexus
launched this product which it claimed
was hallucination free in its ability to
generate legal reports and
reasoning but when Stanford researchers
evaluated Lexus Nexus and West law
products they found that in up to a
third of cases in at least a sixth of
cases these language models
hallucinated um in particular in some
cases the hallucinations basically
completely reversed the intentions of
the original legal text in others the
paragraphs were made up uh they have
about 200 examples of such errors um in
leading ltech
products we've also heard examples of AI
agents soon automating all of scientific
research so this is an example from St
startup Sakana doai Sakana claimed they
had built a research scientist that
could fully automate open-ended
scientific research now our team at
Princeton wanted to test this claim in
the real world in part because
automating scientific research is one of
our main research interests so we built
a benchmark we created this Benchmark
called core bench the tasks in this
Benchmark are way simpler than what you
might expect from open-ended real world
scientific research um they just tried
to reproduce a papers result even
providing the agent with the code and
the data needed to reproduce it so as
you can imagine this is far simpler than
automating all of
science what we found is that the best
agents as of today cannot even automate
scientific research reliably less than
40% of the papers can be um reproduced
by the leading agents now of course you
can see these models getting better and
even if an agent can automate only 40%
of rep producibility that is a huge
boost because researchers spent a lot of
time reproducing baselines from past
results but on this basis to argue that
AI can soon automate all of science or
that agents will R render scientific
researches obsolete is way too
premature in fact when people actually
looked at how well Sakana ai ai
scientist worked they found that it was
deployed on toy problems that uh it was
evaluated using an llm as a judge rather
than than human peer review and that in
fact once you start looking at the
results they turn out to be very minor
tweaks on top of other papers think
undergrad research projects rather than
fully automating all of
Science Now a couple of days ago as I
Was preparing the slides for this talk I
came up with another claim or Sakana
came up with another claim where they
claimed to build an agent for optimizing
Cuda kernels the claims were indeed very
impressive they could lead to a 150x
improvement over the standard could
kernel that P comes with the issue
though was that if you sort of analyze
their claims one level deeper you would
see that they were claiming to
outperform the theoretical maximum of
the H 100 by 30 times clearly this claim
was false and once again it was because
of the lack of rigorous evaluation it
turned out that the agent was simply
hacking the reward function rather than
actually improving the Cuda kernels once
again the point is not to call out a
single company but rather to flag that
evaluating agents is genuinely a very
hard problem it needs to be treated as a
first class citizen in the AI
engineering toolkit or else we continue
risking failures like the ones on the
slide the second reason why building
agents that work in the real world is
hard is because static benchmarks can be
quite misleading when it comes to the
actual performance of
agents and that's because for the
longest time we focused on building
evaluations that might work pretty well
for evaluating High well language models
too but agents are not the same as
models for example for most language
model evaluations all you need to do is
to consider an input string and an
output string those are the domains
where language models work it's really
enough to construct
valuation on the other hand when you're
thinking about agents these agents need
to take actions in the real world they
need to interact with an environment and
so building this s of evaluation that
makes these changes possible that
creates the virtual environments within
which these agents operate is a way
harder
problem a second difficulty in
evaluating agents is that for llms the
cost of evaluating a model is bounded to
the context window length of these
language models you can basically look
at these evaluations as having a fixed
ceiling but when you have agents that
can take open-ended actions in the real
world there isn't any such ceiling you
can imagine these agents calling other
sub agents there can be recursions there
can be all sorts of systems maybe just
llm calls in a for Loop and because of
this Cost needs to be once again a first
class citizen in all evaluations of
Agents if you don't have cost as an
access alongside accuracy or performance
you're not going to really understand
how well your agent
works and finally when you build a new
Benchmark for a language model you can
basically assume that you can evaluate
every single language model model on
this Benchmark but when it comes to
evaluating agents these agents are often
purpose-built so for instance if there
is a coding agent you want to evaluate
you can't really use a web agent
Benchmark to evaluate it on and this
leads to an second hurdle which is how
do you construct these meaningful
multi-dimensional metrics to evaluate
your agents rather than um relying on a
single Benchmark to evaluate how well it
works now all of these concerns might be
thought of as theoretical um you know
you could reasonably ask why do we care
if static evaluations don't really work
well for agents the reason is that
because of these differences with the
cost and the accuracy because of the
single focus on optimizing for a single
Benchmark we are basically unable to get
a coherent picture of how well an agent
works so at Princeton we developed this
uh agent leaderboard that tries to solve
some of these issues in particular for
example for the core bench leader I
mentioned earlier um you can have
multiple agents which are evaluated with
cost alongside accuracy so here on this
parito Frontier you can see agents like
Cloud 3.5 um scoring about as much as
the um open eyes o1 models but a cloud
model actually costs $57 to run whereas
o1 costs
664 even if the performance of open a
Owen was a couple of percentage points
higher which it wasn't in this case by
the way but even it would work for most
AI Engineers the choice here is obvious
you would any day of the week take a
model that costs 10 times lesser while
performing about as
well now in response to this sort of
two-dimensional parito um I've often
been asked um are llms becoming too
cheap to meter in other words why do we
even need to care about the cost of
running an agent if the cost of uh
creating these models is dropping
drastically and it is indeed true that
costs have dropped drastically in the
last few years if you compare Tex
DaVinci 003 which was open AIS model
back in
2022 um to today's GPD 40 mini which in
most cases outperforms this older model
the cost has dropped by over two orders
of
magnitude but at the same time if you're
building applications that need to scale
this type of approach is still quite
costly and especially from the point of
view of releasing prototypes one of the
barriers is for a Engineers is you
really need to sort of iterate in the
open and so if you don't account for
cost your prototype might soon end up
costing you thousands of
dollars and finally even if the cost of
uh scaling inference time um llm calls
continues to drop what is known as a
jvin paradox I suspect will keep
increasing the overall cost of running
agents so jvin Paradox is this Theory
from a 19th century British Economist
who figured out that as the cost of uh
mining coal reduced the overall usage of
coal increased not decreased along
several Industries the same happened
when the ATM machines were introduced
all over the US people expected a loss
of jobs for bank tellers but what
happened was the opposite because ATMs
were so easy to install the number of
Bank branches actually drastically
increased leading to an increase in the
number of bank tellers employed this is
also what I expect will happen as the
costs for language models keep dropping
drastically and that's why for the
foreseeable future at least we do need
to account for cost when it comes to
agent
evaluations so how do we do all of this
um in an automated way well with the
holistic agent leaderboard or Hal uh
we've come up with a way to
automatically run agent evaluations on
these 11 different benchmarks already
and very many more are on the way um
beyond that though even if we come up
with these multi-dimensional um
benchmarks even if we do come up with
cost controlled evalu ations there are
still certain issues with this type of
evaluation and that's because agent
benchmarks have sort of become the
metric against which VC's fund companies
an example is cosign which raised its
seed round of funding based on its
results on S bench in fact agent
developer um cognition raised $175
million at a valuation of $2 billion
driven primarily by the fact that the
Asian did very well on S bench
unfortunately Benchmark performance very
rarely translates into the real world so
this is an excellent analysis of how
well Devon Works Devon is the agent
developed by cognition um from the very
impressive Folks at
answer. um instead of relying on
standard benchmarks they actually tried
to incorporate Devon into the real world
and what they found was that over a
month of use they tried it for 20
different tasks and it was only
successful at three of them so this this
is the other reason why this
overreliance on static benchmarks can be
really
misleading how do we get over this one
of my favorite Frameworks to think
through this is the work by Folks at
Berkeley called who validates the
validators on the top is the typical
evaluation pipeline which consists of
singular llm calls against static
metrics which is the um sort of broken
Paradigm for AI evaluations that we just
discussed and at the bottom is what they
propose they propose having humans in
the loop who are domain experts who
proactively edit the criteria based on
which these llm evaluations are
constructed and that can lead to much
better evaluation results
overall this brings me to the last key
takeaway for why Agent performance does
not really translate into the real world
which is the confusion between what
capability is and what reliability
is so very roughly speaking capability
means what a model could do at certain
points of time for those of of you who
are technically minded this means the
pass at K accuracy of a model for a very
high K that means that one of the K
answers that the model outputs are
correct on the other hand reliability
means consistently getting the answer
right each and every single time when
agents are deployed for consequential
decisions in the real world what you
really need to focus on is reliability
rather than capability that's because
language models are already capable of
very many things but if you trick
yourself into believing this means a
reliable experience for the end user
that's when products in the real world
go wrong so in particular I think the
methods for training models that get us
to the 90% of it what in s's term would
be the job of a machine learning
engineer don't necessarily get us to the
99.999% what is often known as the 5 9
of
reliability and closing this gap between
the 90% And The
99.9% is the job of an AI
engineer and I think this is what has
led to the failures of products like
Humane Spin and rabbit R1 it's because
the developers did not anticipate that
not having reliability in products like
these would lead to a product failure in
other words if your personal assistant
only offers your orders your do Dash
food correctly 80% of the times that is
a catastrophic failure from the point of
view of a
product now one thing people have
proposed to fix this sort of issue to
improve reliability is to create a
verifier something like a unit test um
and on this basis there have been
several claims that we could improve the
inference scaling capabilities of these
tools and get to very reliable
models unfortunately what we found is
that verifiers can also be imperfect in
practice for instance two of the leading
coding benchmarks human eval and mbpp
both have false positives in the unit
tests that is um a model could output
incorrect code and still pass the unit
test and once we account for these false
positives what we have are these
inference scaling curves bending
downwards so rather than model
performance continuing to improve if
there are false positives in your
verifiers the model performance sort of
bends downwards simply because the more
you try the more likely it is you'll get
a wrong
answer and so this is also not a perfect
solution to the problem of
reliability so what is the solution I
think the challenge for AI Engineers is
to figure out what sorts of software
optimizations and abstractions are
needed for working with inherently
stochastic components like llms in other
words it's a system design problem
rather than just a modeling problem
where you need to work around the
constraints of an inherently stochastic
system and I want to argue in the last
one minute of my talk that this means
looking at AI engineering as more of a
reliability engineering field than a
software or a machine learning
engineering field and this also brings
me to the clear mindset shift that is
needed um to become successful for from
the perspective of being an AI engineer
if you look at the title slide of my
talk um this title slide sort of pointed
to one such area where we've already
overcome certain um types of limitations
of stochastic
systems and that is with the birth of
computing the 1946 eniac computer used
over 17,000 vacuum tubes many of which
at the beginning of this process used to
fail so often that the computer was
unavailable half the time and the
engineers who built this product knew
that this is a failure from the point of
view of the end users so their primary
job in the first two years of this
computer was to fix the reliability
issues to reduce it to a point where it
becomes well enough it works well enough
to become usable by the end user and I
say that this is precisely what AI
Engineers need to be thinking about as
their real job it is not to create
excellent products though that is
important but rather to fix the
reliability issues that plague every
single agent that uses inherently
stochastic models um as its basis so
this is what I'll leave you here with
today um to become successful Engineers
you need a reliability shift in your
mindset to think of yourselves as the
people who are ensuring that this next
wave of computing is as reliable for end
users as possible and there's a lot of
precedent for this type of thing
happening in the past all right with
this I'll leave you with the 3K
takeaways it was a pleasure being here
thank you
[Music]